is the American Dream crumbling a new
poll says that nearly six out of ten
people say that the American Dream is
now impossible to achieve in this
country this is a poll from CNN money's
American Dream poll conducted by o RC
International so young adults aged 18 to
34 well I'm not even in that group
anymore that it said are most likely to
feel the dream is unattainable with 63
percent saying it's impossible that is
incredibly depressing 63 percent of all
Americans said most children in the US
won't be better off than their parents
and 67 percent of Americans say they
have not achieved the American dream I
remember when I was in tenth grade or
eleventh grade I took a class I think it
was like a social studies like an
offshoot social studies class and the
teachers saying that you guys are gonna
be the first generation that in America
that's gonna be worse off than their
parents and I remember like that like
hit me like oh [ __ ] like this and now
it's a that was 20 years ago and now
it's actually happening how disturbing
is this I mean as a member of the
generation that they were I think I
think the idea of the American Dream has
definitely evolved you know and I think
it's a lot different for young people
today you know I say if anything we are
the access generation access means more
to us and I think it should then
ownership Kevin Kelley who's a
phenomenal author he talks a lot about
you know technology and futures and
stuff says that access is better than
ownership and I believe that you know we
live in the age of uber you know it's
you can Obert today with greater ease
than it is owning a freakin car you can
Airbnb you know places all around the
world rather than owning a house and I
think that some it's just a different
world we live in you know like it's
better to have access to things than to
own stuff and and so I'm perfectly okay
with that you know Wow a little a little
hope off a depressing study what do you
think I mean obviously the American
Dream is sort of vague and amorphous and
and you know it is what you think it is
but as far as the idea of people not
thinking that they aren't going to do
better than their parents I mean that is
sadly the reality and I think that all
kind of stems from everything since
Ronald Reagan basically has been about
the dismantling of the 20th
century the dismantling of you know
labor unions the dismantling of voting
rights the dismantling of everything
that was making us a more perfect union
and that was providing education for
people and and you know the the this was
the country that that you know went to
the moon I got all the stuff that we
accomplished when we got past the Gilded
Age we're now back to the Gilded Age
we're now back to the you know the point
one percent and then the rest of us and
I think and and and as you said the
point one percent by the way cuz it's
not the 1 percent we've talked about
many times the one percent makes
somewhere around $400,000 which
obviously is great I don't make anywhere
near that but those aren't the people
that are really in that top echelon the
tiny amount of people who control the
massive amounts of wealth the tax breaks
they have been given by taking their
money offshore by taking jobs offshore
by not reinvesting in their companies
you know and instead just hoarding it
off somewhere that is this is the Reagan
effect this is the country we live in
now this is the country where where was
was once the land of opportunity and is
now not so much
I like this we had hope and now we have
know about we should you know every
generation should reassess what it means
to do good you know like are we happier
what the three is sure are we safer you
know are we do we fuel you know more
sort of creatively expressed you know so
that though then seems like the scary
part to me because if 63 percent are
saying that that dream is impossible
even though the hopi parts that you gave
which are pretty good even though those
exist these people still don't think
that whatever the idea of the dream is
of happiness that's the part I think is
interesting here maybe happiness is is
unattainable I don't know if that study
is is you know questioned you know
Millennials whether or not they thought
they believed that the dream is
impossible whatever you think the dream
is if you're saying it's impossible it
seems like it might affect your
happiness right yeah I know it wasn't an
index is a subjective thing the dream I
guess yeah I don't know I think that we
have the tools to be happier than our
there are parents you know or maybe not
honestly don't know no I mean I I think
you're right a lot of it's very
subjective I don't think you know if the
American Dream used to be
about I don't know owning a home in the
suburbs clearly that's not as much of
the goal anymore and and I you know I
agree with you that we were moving away
from the sort of idea of you know that
it was about possessions or about you
know these sort of you know marks lines
in the sand you had to accomplish to to
be a success or to achieve the dream but
as far as just the basic of you know my
parents were immigrants to this country
and they wanted their kids have more
opportunities they would have had if
they'd stayed in Spain and I think that
parents want their kids to do better and
now we're looking at kids realizing
that's not gonna happen and that's kind
of demoralizing yeah that is a scary
thought I want to spin this positively
before we go max give me one final
thought that's gonna make everyone feel
really good about the futures in my say
a couple buzz words oculus rift I'll be
pretty oh so you can live in a virtual
yeah yeah you look forward to that in a
virtual happy world okay very good